now new surveillance video tonight after
a robbery left a man fighting for his
life in chinatown thank you for joining
us at six i'm brian loftus and i'm
denise valdez so that victim shot a
staggering number of times nearly a
dozen and tonight the i-team's vanessa
murphy takes us inside the restaurant
where it all went down
metro police are searching for the
suspect who shot an employee here at
shanghai taste in chinatown early monday
morning 11 times the employee is
recovering in the hospital now the
managing partner here at the restaurant
tells me this is the door the suspect
came through metro police have video of
the suspect again they are asking for
help to solve this crime i have the
managing partner here with me
tell me how the employee is doing he's
much better thank you for asking he uh
today he went second surgery which had
us a little alarmed but we were relieved
to find out that it was on his shoulder
because he was also shot in his shoulder
yesterday's surgery was the one that was
the most life-threatening it was the
neck we went through the neck tomorrow
they will do a surgery on his hands but
we still have not able to speak to him
because he's still not conscious
and metro police announced today they
believe that this crime is linked to a
previous recent burglary in the same
shopping center that was not reported to
police this information just coming out
today detectives saying they just
learned this today so again they believe
the two crimes are linked and you told
me that you believe that he was i'm just
going to step over here you believe he
was mopping up the actual mop itself was
all the way stretched out which looked
like he had been shot and maybe fell he
might have got up a lot of concentration
a lot of bullet holes here here this
bullet went right through here and went
out the other side
there's the bullet down there bullet
hole down there
this was all bullet holes here so there
was a fight and all this glass panel was
blown out
so you know
in a way we're fortunate he was a really
bad aim and i know you're looking for
chen young wong's family in china we're
going to find his family it's just not
going to be something we could do right
away
we don't know how to even begin so and
we're not allowed any information at
this time at the hospital because we're
not family so
okay thank you so much for talking with
us metro police are asking anyone with
information to come forward reporting in
chinatown vanessa murphy live local now
we can also tell you tonight here at six
metro is increasing patrols around that
shopping center off of spring mountain
if you have any information as to who
may have done this please call crime
stoppers